cette bâche représente le château de
dampierre lors de sa construction au
xviie siècle de 120 mètres de long 25
mètres de haut elle doit entourer les
échafaudages pendant les travaux les
jardins reste ouvert au public présenté
les échafaudages valorisé par cette
bâche qui représente l'ancien château de
dampierre le château version jules
hardouin mansart
c'est grâce à des archives que nous
avons retrouvé dans le grenier eh bien
c'était un moyen de valoriser et de
communiquer sur ce chantier auprès du
public pour chaque façade il y a une
façade bien distinctes puisque dans les
cartons nous avions eu la chance de
trouver les quatre façades représenter à
la fin du xviie siècle
ces travaux de restauration vont durer
36 mois les compagnons vont travailler
sur les murs de l'enceinte et sur la
toiture recouverte par un parapluie
l'objectif c'est de maintenir l'existant
c'est à dire de restaurer là où c'est
nécessaire
les enduits les menuiseries de rebelles
et les rénover les restaurer car sans
les remplacer
et puis la couverture malheureusement il
faudra elle l'a remplacé et vérifier que
la charpente soit évidemment
suffisamment solide pour continuer à
traverser les siècles
ce projet s'inscrit dans un cadre plus
global de restauration des jardins et de
l'intérieur du château une volonté du
propriétaire avec un investissement
global de 50 millions d'euros
ce programme se continue sur les jardins
sur les réseaux faire qu'on va refaire
la cour et refaire tous les réseaux la
mise aux normes des réseaux sur les
jardins et bien tout autour de nous les
jardins à la française qu'on attribue à
le nôtre vont être restaurés avec les
bassins les jets d'eau et puis enfin une
fois que l'échafaudage sera tombée et
bien il y aura la restauration
intérieure pour visiter l'intérieur du
château il faudra attendre 2024 avec sa
réouverture au public en 2010 9 plus de
20000 visiteurs ont parcouru les allées
du parc du château de dampierre en
yvelines